as always can you hear us I'm Greg I'm
John we're the real rejects and today
we're gonna talk about your guilty
pleasures hey Chris why off did you see
your shout out buddy
all right guys can you hear us it's the
first order of business it's a first
order of business the first order we
need to know if you can hear us there's
several people in this chat and it's
saying zero highs are on the stream
right now can you hear us
mm-hmm my goodness is it hello everyone
TM locale Johnson dela m'kay songbird
Kingman travels alone oh there we go
keep it with the names yeah there's some
sound verifications there okay good good
good did you guys see our venom venom
and carnage carnage reaction Pizza Hut
in a garage that sounds like a great
idea
we should start franchising stores like
that into people's garages and houses
because then like you could supply your
neighborhood you could really like
there's some headway to be made there so
let me ask you guys right away how is
everything going with social distancing
in court eating have you lost your
[ __ ] mind yet or are you doing all
right
what's up to Toronto hey-oh
oh my god Matt Sondra that's way too
kind of you way too kind of you here we
go I forget we have that okay I forget
we have that so guys ask some questions
at the very top before we went live and
I asked whatever like who hovers in the
chat beforehand what their guilty
pleasure films are we got some fun ones
Jacob says gremlins too Carter says
Ferris Bueller's Day Off guilty pleasure
really first Bueller's Day Off is
considered a generally a good movie yeah
somebody else said like Studio Ghibli
films that I'm like I'm pretty sure all
of those have massive respect and then
the Cloverfield pair someone said
Cloverfield yeah I can see that too you
know what my favorite guilty pleasure is
okay I got two one I know is a bad movie
but I love and the other one is a film
that I just know
everyone hates but for some reason I
really enjoy it
I think it's genuinely good and that
would have to be the first one that I
know is bad but I love this street
fighter who I'm going to kick and Bisons
ass so hard and the other one would have
to be the film that no one likes but I
genuinely I'm like I just don't think
anyone gets it I think it's a really
funny movie and it's genuinely good the
dark world love in this chat right now
that's a movie I feel like I go back and
re-watch because it's taken on such a
shape in my head and it has almost no
like actual recollection from the time I
saw oh hey Ian Ian Stu tell well thank
you so much buddy you do that you tell
oh you guys should make a Jojo Rob it's
a movie to reveal I'm it's because of
the fact that he's saying
Jojo rabbit I'm like maybe we should do
a Jojo rally yeah yeah quick review
right here
I think Jojo rabbit is absolutely one of
the best movies of last year I think
taiko YTD road like a near impossible
line because he managed to do a film
that was you know commentary on a very
sensitive time in a very sensitive
subject make it wildly funny but also
make it incredibly heartfelt it was just
absolutely beautiful Scarlett Johansson
is one of her best performances ever oh
yeah though who's a little boy oh like
an amazing child yeah incredible [ __ ]
child yeah I know his name and I can't
draw it to mine right now it'll come to
me yeah I just keep thinking of Logan
Lerman and it's not him yeah yeah that
kid like it's the the young cast in
general in that movie is really terrific
and to get such a lived-in performance
for a kid so small and he doesn't come
across like an actor type kid like even
just watching him the award shows he
seems just like a regular cute kid I
completely
I completely agree with that and also
psycho white Edie's performance was
incredible - oh my god I'm seeing love
here for Last Action Hero that's another
movie - for a guilty pleasure that I
absolutely enjoy and ice
is a film is you know what I think
that's a movie that's become appreciated
over time ooh
totally pan but I hear more and more
people praising that movie not praising
but saying they like it oh and I really
like that movie a lot I genuinely add
that oh my god that is we just got a
super chapter actually we're behind a
foe
we're Brittany lang where's Brittany
Lang in the house well fine we'll find
them we're going through the comments
one at a time the mummy 99 is actually a
good movie I don't I don't know why I
keep submitting throughout this chat I
just want to keep seeing more guilty
pleasure films coming Batman Forever
there you go there's a guilty man
forever it's a hard one to sit through
Oh Brittany laying John dear Canadian
accent we're running out of voices on
that hello from Vancouver Canada
question any movie or shows you can
recommend on Netflix to watch yeah
I've been talking a lot about this
Castlevania startup Castlevania if you
haven't done so already that's an
awesome show just finished the first
season for whole 25-minute episodes
that's right I know how to time manage
and then the other one I would say is a
lock and key I really do enjoy that show
a lot if you're not caught up and better
call Saul start better call Saul most of
them is on Netflix so I would go with
that Britney and thank you so much
you're super chat thank you thank you
thank you how's Canada doing it's Canada
under quarantine
I feel like Mexico is dealing what I
haven't heard any craziness about yeah I
have a couple friends up in Canada who
are struggling with what we're
struggling with although you guys can
weigh in and tell us how it's different
and tell us how it's the same that's
true good point good point
I see street fighter a lot of a lot of
love for street fighter here Halloween
three season of the witch is another one
that I'm seeing a lot of love for yeah
it keeps coming in that's it that's
another one that I constantly hear from
fans that film is resurged might yes in
the past decade yes absolutely now that
everyone gets the idea the John you
probably have a better Norman Reedus and
none of my impressions are good I'm
gonna rely on John's impressions
Boondock Saints my favorite
forget guilty wall also spawn is a
guilty pleasure Rick you're somewhere
between M and M yeah yeah anytime you're
super chairman of force John and do a
new impression of someone yeah with the
boondocks Rockville thank you so much
the Prince that wasn't promised is that
you is this little boy right here you're
not supposed to be using YouTube or
being advertised too young if you are
using your parents card why only ten
make it a thousand the limit and no
refunds
haven't you seen home alone Jase is a
blast I've never seen the sequel though
have you guys seen the sequel I've never
seen the sequel and um that director fun
fact about that guy blacklisted like a
[ __ ] oh yeah oh one movie and then
the only other movie he was able to make
was that sequel that came out many years
later I haven't seen any Boondock Saints
but I did see Sean Patrick Flanery in
person no yeah at the grocery I've made
Norman Reedus walk around for two hours
and death surrounding and nothing has
happened in that game so far
oh you praying by the way just finish
spider-man on ps4 incredible got a
shout-out my brother Jabby Kawai for
giving that to me forever ago Shanna
Tyler Haig for giving me a ps4 it's a
mad mad world is a genuinely good movie
and here's the man who brought up like
Jason Nunez chasm is dachshund noodle
these are quality live streams is what
happens to be hanging out with us on
Saturday night after a fun week hey Raj
what's going on guys King gave me
alright Shazam is a great okay do you
guys what a guilty pleasure is there I'm
sandy pleasure of movies that are not
perceived generally as a good movie that
you would feel on healing I a guilty
pleasure of mine is the human centipede
yeah feel weird meeting that or Twilight
yeah or something yet no one's seen
Justice League and I defend the [ __ ] out
of that I don't see I feel like that net
moving you what it was spider-man 3
especially a bully McGuire guilty
pleasure all the way Roman Griffin Davis
was that
yeah yeah the little Jojo rabbit boy
right right right
what else is in this oh my god was that
jab jab eco is in this chat Abbas Co
Abbas is here I thought he was filming a
corridor a crew reaction right now he
lied to you my seat full son of a bee
gees what family does family lies family
should always lie that's how you keep a
relationship healthy just good advice
for the kids watching um
Carter Lovejoy my guilt thank you so
much Carter Lovejoy CJ Carter Lovejoy
my guilty pleasure is the first spike
it's um that's my Antonio Banderas
impression it's just typical to Spaniard
yeah responsible from nobody put my
chicken that's that's I used to do
Banderas impression where I would
compliment act like on complimenting
women and but I'm really insulting them
and not realizing so it'd be like
because if you character and her teeth
listening in the night as yellow as my
urine
I'm literal with that joke when I was 13
years old I know kills flashing back to
the black box theater you used to bring
it I fit in Carter Lovejoy I guess my
kids one is considered good right I
think it's the most agreeable one people
generally like it I think that's where I
first heard oh [ __ ] tashi mushroom
oh [ __ ] sake mushroom no have not seen
Wakefield oh my god Archer PA your
grandma just turned 80 thank you so much
John do your best old white man
impression what's up guys celebrated my
gpa's 80th bday not not concerned here
about the coronavirus not one bit
my kids have locked me up in the Attic
I'm not allowed I haven't seen sunlight
or other humans for days a plate of food
appears out of my door every night
whatever your dad would you get your
grandpa ferns 80th birthday what are
you're crazy
tell me a strippers revenge of the
revenge of the SIP is the best the
prequels if you said Phantom Menace I
would give it to you some people are
saying Revenge of the Sith
Iron Man two
almost I like things about it I don't
hate Ironman - yeah yeah because you
like Michael B's question of why would
anyone be guilty of liking laughs it's
not like one movie makes you guilty for
likey to feel guilty pleasure is damn it
Oh Suspiria oh man is it considered a
beauty always not to go through my gosh
we need we know we need it is off screen
and make it clear wanted edition on
screen yes okay
Oh Matthew thank you so much man
chandram all right John could you
imagine a flix Batman going up against
heats Joker that dynamic would have been
amazeballs also love you guys been
watching forever I love you look at your
face my god that beard is so crisp right
now you're the kind of subscriber that
would I meet them in person I go oh why
are subscribers so much better looking
at the rest of us and the rest of us
being me you know it gives you something
to work towards uh yeah I mean Affleck's
Batman going up against Heath Ledger
would have been way cooler than a flicks
batman going up against and you know
that morbius guy the dude who was
meditating in the mountains for 12 weeks
straight eyes closed feeding through a
straw but thank you thank you so much
Matthew John that's really sweetie warm
bodies is a good light we reviewed that
positive positivity warm bodies I think
is actually an underrated rom-com flick
I liked it a lot
rubber baby buggy bumpers what is that
it's just a tongue twister don't mess
with me okay Batman forever I've seen a
lot of love for Batman Forever guys if
you haven't submitted your guilty
pleasure films be sure to keep them
going in this Chapel reading imagine
tornado there you go
hello lollie hi lolly see
Oh mwah kisses for you how are you thank
you for oh oh this is the real deal this
is ASMR now you guys hear that what's
for you Lily giggling your cheek
don't tell your boyfriend or husband or
wife or girl to tell your son and
telling the show but my doorstep cake is
that so should you go do you should go
around threatening parents to beat their
children oh now we're getting some real
guilty pleasures are in here boy
Sharkboy and Lavagirl that if you liked
that movie definitely a kiltie but you
should feel guilty oh we always say
opinions on movies are subjective but
we're qualifying what is objective at
this point and sharp or Lavagirl is not
a good no John Roca and what's up but
Hudson Hawk yo John Roku loves chairman
everyone know that go check out the
outlaw nation channel I wish we could
pass you in right now
love's terrible films he mainly
recommends bad movies I was on we were
on a bus with him going Angel Stadium he
was a huge Rambo fan oh yeah Rambo 5 he
wishes our most disliked video ever
because we didn't like him but 5 so
maybe were in the minority we like good
movies that no one else seems weird as
your girlfriend Roca say hi to your
mother for me oh I love this
oh I thought he was explaining to me
what guilty is not okay Incredible Hulk
I guess so Breakfast Club amazing
spider-man 2 yeah yeah give it to you
why not
javi kawaii Thank You super sticker oh
it's a poop he sent us a poop sticker he
sent us a poop sticker yeah you can't
see it on the stream we're using here
but on YouTube it is there it is it's a
little poop with a smile I'll send him a
text later giving him some serious
talking there's the room nipple chills I
love Yuka you know what's great about
this nipple chills is a genuine thing
that happens to me and I'm sure it
happened okay now I'm gonna throw
another question out to all you guys in
the chat and yeah we're going through
this whole thing we're reading
everything
all right so what's your guilty
pleasures that's one two when you get
body chills off of like something being
awesome do you also get nipple chills or
or other chills it's like that if
there's anything that's been great about
the channel it's that that has become my
catchphrase it's on a t-shirt
Tyra might have 1 million subscribers
now 10 I have nipple Joe if you know I
am okay with that behind our Spreadshirt
you can Emblaze in your own chest with
the phrase Archer PA oh John does a
great Nick Cage this is a genuinely good
one it's good it's a great impression
it's one of the best NIC cages
impressions you'll ever hear it's so
good no way in hell well Johnson Cage
impression ever let you down and there's
nothing about it you could criticize
where you can possibly go this is a bad
Nic Cage impression John show them the
perfect Nic Cage impression you do no
pressure
show them the perfect Nic Cage
impression my guilty pleasure I'm a
pleasure protector drive anglish
starring Nicolas Cage I said angly
driving Li drive Angeles that's the
sequel to drive angry yes him going on a
road trip with it'll be a revitalization
of those BMW films but now Nicolas Cage
has to get Angley to the set of Gemini
man 2 starring me and John Travolta I'm
in Hell watching yeah hey I think Drive
anger is great there's Ness star Johnny
Depp's Amber Heard yeah really respected
ex-wife yeah who is totally getting
brownie points right now all over the
internet and all the leaks that are
coming out totally oh dude but you know
who's great in dry bhangra there's one
thing that everyone can agree on and
plus I love the plot of that and I think
the actor who John will totally bring up
for me right now
William William Fichtner William
Fichtner is incredible in that film if
you guys haven't seen Drive Angry it's
I think it's a blast of a film it's it's
it's a b-movie and those screenwriters
said that they wrote that in like one
day yeah I believe they were like they
sat down they didn't do any notes are
like and it has that vibe though I I
think driving is actually a pretty
pretty fun film and it's designed very
knowing of what it is yeah it was
intended as a guilty pleasure you know a
street fighter yes I said grease -
haven't seen grease - all right grease -
is I think that's King guilty pleasure
right there or Queen guilty play hey
Shona the - is to go and Yusef ash
refers back what's up buddy Godzilla
2017 that's considered a good one he's -
what's up Haley
I saw this in the theaters Congo
genuinely geeky guys you know Congo
scared me when I was a kid it barely
wait it's this big apron um no that's uh
that's King Kong like - there was Congo
and there were some other ones well
they're a Congo is a big ape one uh well
from that time I always remember people
freaking out about anaconda with Jon
Voight and Owen Wilson Jennifer Asia
Anika Honda - verse King Kong versus God
that should be their time anomie when
they decide to make an alliance where is
the Anaconda franchise when you need it
yeah true dinner top off the way I had
hoped personally guilty pleasures keep
submitting them below guys keep getting
the hill thank you genuinely geeky guys
geeks rule the world now buddy the
Batman movie has stopped oh there's not
making it this isn't probably gonna pan
out
breaking news some movies are being
delayed or postponed indefinitely other
movies rather than [ __ ] this don't want
to make it anymore yeah you know what
just scrap the film we're not picking it
up junk it all take it home Sonic the
Hedgehog I guess I would say as a guilty
pleasure High School Musical yes
absolutely
nan I remember High School Musical 3
that trailer played before a midnight
screening of The Dark Knight and it was
a mixed full theater of
boos and laughter yes booing and
laughing that's my main association when
I think of High School Musical it was it
was a especially poor placement of that
yes that's a Freddie's movie happening
yeah plum house they've livid wicked one
house one house those great films or
terrible films you know that's it that's
what's good about them and they and they
seem to organize them that way yeah
Oh John John Nick Cage ah I don't know
if you guys heard this but John does a
perfect Nick Cage impression
take it away John con errors another or
guilty pleasure
cuz I'm a pleasure protector all right
now it's not do John Malkovich saying
that's just a rock that's just a rock he
doesn't deliver it like I know not seen
Connor it's been a very long time and I
saw it on TNT with lots of commercials
and a silly swear replacements Connor is
a josh mokuba John Roca kind of movie
there for fun you know what I got blast
that's a blast of a film I think he came
at the same years face off it's a fun
film and I'm mostly I think focusing on
the fact that Dave Chappelle was in it
yes I think that's what I got really
excited for there's the poop oh my god
oh thank you thank you javi Kawai he's
gonna text me asking for this money back
he's gonna tell me to venmo him yeah I
just did this for analytics so sweet of
you so sweet of you man some of your
Indian audience this way
okay so Legally Blonde maybe Legally
Blonde - I would say yeah yeah Oh
vampires kiss isn't that the one with
Nicolas Cage oh yeah oh man we there's a
lot more our chats coming in here than I
realize were happy jaws - ha ha that's a
great one Ace Ventura and a half what is
that is that the one with a little boy
oh maybe oka armpit chills oh I just saw
armpit chills
no hit that yeah no we're back on
there's just so much for the system to
handle all right okay so there's so many
cool comments coming and it's actually
getting hard to keep up with being able
to flash them is supercharged a Pico am
origins Wow that is a truly guilty
pleasure
all right we're going all over the place
here with some of these chats oh my god
Lana Pico
how's the babe noms mightyjoyoung she
got it yes I can see the trailer yes
mightyjoyoung because I was thinking a
condom like what was the other one
though was mighty Joe Young was the
uplifting version was like conker was
the horrifying Thank You Lana so much I
know you're not actually pregnant
that's a reoccurring joke we have Oh
John talk to Lana and your Nic Cage
voice I'm proud to be your baby daddy
but what I want to be even more is your
baby's daddy I feel like that's one
extra step up I want to break out of
that cage so sweet Lana how the ye
handle in this situation your Hawaii
right how's the situation going over
there things going okay yeah okay oh
we're gonna make midsummer a harem it's
a Mars an actual good movie yeah it's
just a good film another directors cuts
great to lots over baby daddies baby
daddies yeah I don't want anything to do
with that I'll be baby daddies for the
both of us
Megan is real public right now take me
to court all you want ain't happening
not being there for that kid ain't
happening
our Joe Mike Archer PA Wow
so any time you answer us you're just
gonna talk to somebody who's dressed up
to stay inside real fast deep rising
that's a great movie total guilty
pleasure of mine to you I share that
with you
Waterworld I would say this h1 is deep
rising because I'm thinking of deep in
deep risings kind of like this monster
and the water obviously they're like on
a ship and there's like bad guys who are
like modern-day pirates has Benny from
the first mummy movie in there has some
not from Street Fighter and they're OK
by Archer PA real fast we celebrated
GEEP Osbert we celebrated my GPA from a
distance grandpa's birthday from a
distance the family and I have a chorus
Oh singing happy birthday dropped off
funny t-shirt it was washed I hope so
also Nic Cage oppression
while William Fichtner stole that film
absolutely well tell your grandpa happy
birthday for us shouted at him though
from somewhere far and I'll make sure to
send him a box of used tissues and
toilet paper
freshly rewashed you know yes that works
Trump said our dryer and the and the
building's not working but you know he
can do is leave it in the Sun probably
benefit off the moist that it comes with
yeah you know it'll help him rehydrate
just stay hydrated don't show your dad
or your grandpa any of what we just said
all right so real fast load we're gonna
cat okay what else do we got here the
Wolverines a good movie guys come on
keep it up okay let's let's expand this
now let's expand this guilty-pleasure
movies okay
do you also get nipple chills and guilty
pleasure TV shows shows that are
generally considered not good good you
know you're able to you you you you you
do like them yourself
Yusef Ashraf welcome back it's been a
while since we've seen you I've already
shattered how do you not pay attention
about his neck Asian press yeah that's
all I'm doing here she's living up to
that beautiful and how are the duck
that's a foam Italy hey you guys know
how to quarantine we got a valiant
people in here you guys know how to
quarantine it up I do the only positive
videos I've seen from the quarantine
situation our neighbors in Italy playing
music playing music with each other we
don't do that here you guys not to did
no well we do wrestle each other yes the
hair annoyed if you get too close to us
we're gonna sock you in the face that's
how we operate every time I've been to a
store lately the second someone coughs
everybody I see envision reacts Matthew
Chandra guys going on an MCU marathon
finished Panther endgame
oh and haven't seen that one both
guardians Ironman was wow you're you're
doing a weird-ass order what's your
favorite and Cu film ever
alright look I've been on record Thank
You Matthew Chandra by the way that's
really kind of you I've been on record
many times saying it's endgame I'm gonna
tell you guys my second favorite one
then instead because I don't talk about
it that often
and that would be guardians of the
galaxy that's my
in favor one for sure and it look do I
really need to say more all right it's
his garden to the galaxy it's hilarious
space opera energetic some of the best
action I think in the MCU spectacle
Rocket Raccoon like come on it's
guardians of the galaxy yeah and that
and that movie at the time was a breath
of fresh air in marble steal my answer
no I'm not supporting your choice
because you make good choices what's
your oh here here we go what's the MCU
guilty pleasure huh what's an MCU guilty
pleasure an MCU guilty pleasure yeah
there are no guilty pleasures in the MCU
they're all [ __ ] amazing even hey
Lana you're getting a lot of love in
this chat by the way hey too fast too
furious I'll meet you there that's a
guilty pleasure of mine too ding we're
okay this damn program is not keeping up
here we're gonna have to read off some
of these super chats really fast here
who have we missed we got to make sure
we didn't miss anyone because we like to
be fair and go and order while keeping
up with the regular chat as well we got
these people who just don't touch the
mouse don't don't don't journey I did a
mouse alene don't germ the mouse already
risk myself being here with your sweaty
ass all day that's right Terminator
songs thanks so much do you appreciate
it no question hey Tim in there songs
good director makes great beats good
rapper yeah
princess unicorn nipples I know you get
nipple chills for sure some of the man
she is saying son of the mask I haven't
seen that one I have ever seen some of
the mask no no I have not sighs I saw
the mask in the theaters actually but no
dude the masses and it still holds up
really well but yeah son of the math you
know what movie I rely my girlfriend had
never seen this before
Austin Powers international manners
you've never seen it still [ __ ] funny
there's some outdated [ __ ] but still
pretty [ __ ] hilarious
I'm not gonna lie all right real thank
you so much princess unicorn nipples
take care of your nipple chills for us
would you
Queen of the Damned oh you know what I
would say to Queen of the Damned people
really like this movie I don't think
it's good but I enjoy cuz I think it's
so bad interview with the vampire queen
and the Damned is a weird case because I
feel like and maybe it's because of the
circumstances with alia perhaps that it
has taken on a more benevolent I think
hindsight but yeah yeah yeah I would say
a queen and a mime yeah but interview
with a vampire that's movie I don't
think is good but I enjoy it because I
think it's so bad it's good that's my
perspective little bit of a hot take the
audio is not sync with the video okay
you got to understand so it happens
sometimes laughter especially here
because everyone's using the internet it
takes like six hours to upload a regular
YouTube video now and to get this
quality or using the DSLR which is a
much bigger video yeah you know it's
gonna happen I apologize I apologize
alright who else to be Halley
researching thank you so much thoughts
on Greece to John take it away in your
best John Travolta impression sandy I
can't do charge both I don't even know
where oh yeah thought some greasy now
down now I'm gonna hey Lee how's it
going
hey Lee how you doing out in the
Tennessee first of all Greece to I mean
you've showed me like a lot like you
exposed me to Greece and then you know
you exposed me to several numbers from
Greece to and oh that's Haley that's
Haley yeah that's this mark yeah mm-hmm
HP Lovecraft hey Haley we've met a
couple times yeah so um she came on to
me way too hard I mean I can tell you're
irresistible
I fear friends I feel like I need to sit
down and really give Greece to another
full hearted viewing but I don't think
it deserves the stigma that it is built
throughout history and it needs to come
back in some kind of revival house
scenario we need to do like a medley of
like
to shock treatments all the sequel
musicals nobody cared that Saturday
Night Fever - oh my god someone just
named Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
longtime patronage act on the media go
check out this channel Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers you know what it smells
like in here teenager what I did I made
it seem like I was talking about
something in the actual room I thought
it was gonna be my sweaty ass but I was
quoting Ivan I have a news I don't know
was it I mean I thought he's got a
Robert Englund II thing to me no need to
look it up I don't know the names of any
of those actors you know ruin but him
the guy who plays Tommy is a Fitness
channel on YouTube guys keep the guilty
pleasures coming keep them Serbian film
was getting a good amount of prison here
my god these are our viewers I don't
know I think Serbian film transcends
guilt and anything like if you're it's
not even a guilty pleasure it's like a
depraved pleasure yeah that's a good
point here alright okay okay alright
Niraj thank you no Raj Krishna nobody
shouts out to you Waterworld is my
guilty pleasure movie because Kevin
Costner speaks in Hindi for the first
few minutes of the movie did you see
John's would you do a story or a wrap I
did a story about neurons I'd check out
your patron shout out people good it was
a fave thank you so much Niraj already
one of our top patrons and and now
you're you're contributing us feel more
guilty I I don't feel guilt at all I
would say you got incoming - I go yeah
be mindful thank you
Waterworld that you know it doesn't
matter if you think Waterworld is a
terrible movie or not if you've been to
Universal Studios theme park which you
could go to right now Universal Studios
being part the the the show yeah which
hasn't changed its script
at all no since it came out like
20-something years ago it's the one
thing in the park that's holding strong
every single time I go and I generally
go to Universal Studios at least once
every other year a minimum that show is
still spectacular it's like the same
script they just get different actors
different stunt performers who do
incredible stunts in that show and it
still holds up it is in so you know like
it's much as bad as Waterworld is they
at least have that live show which is
amazing and they haven't today they swap
out rides and attractions all the time
they've gotten a riddle they want a
classic rocket Romano water I wish they
would bring back slaughter world but
which is their Halloween show I wish
they bring back Wow Wow Wes that was fun
oh yes
I got Wade Oh princess unicorn nipple
said he eat that's what I say you and I
nipple chill didn't I go eat I feel like
I always jump cut after an Avengers
trailer I just don't want people to see
me going that's your version of the
Conan hip strings a walk the line is not
a guilty pleasure
that's a genuinely kidding damn good
movie great cast great director mr. H
reviews I have seen some mortal cup
mortal kombat yes man is there any word
on if that stopped that I mean the new
one is that done filming is there a
production going on that because that
one is a is a great film hmm I mean I
that will be a great film
I have faith they'll be a great one at
least the best video game movie but I
love the original Mortal Kombat I've met
the actor play Shang Tsung mmm yeah
that's at me and he's like your soul is
mine this jokes gonna [ __ ] up it's a
shitty joke it's [ __ ] that [ __ ] that
joke I can't no the joke was your soul
is mine I was like I'm not confident in
this I'm not gonna deliver it okay but
you know who else what happened to Robin
Shou
play Liu Kang he was great man hmm the
Star Wars sequels are guilty oh my god
Jason Nunez yes
Super Mario Brothers yeah where we
finally learned their last name is just
Mario where Bob Hoskins John Leguizamo
way to authentic brothers from Italy and
Dennis Hopper is the classic villain
King Koopa yeah man he's great in it
yeah totally oh my god no he's any
Bowser
yeah he's Betty's Lupe's are the ones
who are like we read those those are
yeah met people who look like them and
that's not a good look change your
physique and face thank you by the way
pretty weird super tan we're not
flashing at it that's just because of
our server that's not doing it but so we
were try our best to make sure we're not
missing anyone here Teen Wolf I hear is
a great show flat final destination I
like that one I like final destination I
don't this nation's but Twin Peaks is
not a guilty pleasure
people love Twin Peaks there seems to be
a lot of love for Ace Ventura and a half
in this chat right now Hannah Montana oh
you know what show I really liked
Wizards of Waverly Place
I don't Emmy award-winning Disney
Channel show so maybe that doesn't count
not that guilty Rover Dangerfield Tim
inator song thank you some oh oh
Brittany Lang I'll thank you so much
Neal a oh that's that's that's okay
been off work for three weeks I'm so
sorry all right well why are you tipping
okay tell you what here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna read your super
chat in a really positive enthusiastic
voice a lot of business heat our have a
lot of take to a lot of businesses are
having a hard time in Canada I've been
off work for three weeks so it's been a
tough of majority of realest Realty
retail I mean today my god it's been
tough the majority are close to stop the
spread of the virus but over we are
managing in Canada so it's okay all
right
we're headed to Canada I just keep
imagining you Britney with this like
smile on your face just like keeps
he's smiling tough time in all sincerity
though I don't I don't know saying this
Tamaki all right we're just having some
fun but I'm not mocking you it's we it's
it's even been pretty scary around this
household some situation financial stuff
that's been brought to our front door so
yeah I appreciate you being here
but and for yeah contribute to the super
chat but I I can't imagine how tough of
a situation has been for you are you at
least still getting like some type of
check right now our awesome president is
currently working something out where we
can get checks depending on the certain
income you get but so I don't know what
the Canada policy is are you guys
getting some type of payment in the
meantime are you can employment pay are
they putting moratoriums on evictions
and do you guys have testing for the
virus out there I know you guys got that
awesome universal health care stuff so
are you guys able to still get tested
for free though you know what I read
yesterday is you boy over making the
vacuums in the hand washers dice and
just made a brand new ventilator
respirator machine that can apparently
be like man they've made it in like ten
days like design to production and now
they're making a bunch of shipping
amount so that's pretty inspiring just
sidebar and Brittany Lang what do you do
for a living by the way I think I feel
like we've talked about this maybe yeah
once or remind us what you do for a
living you stay sexy we are like believe
the hype a princess unicorn nipples
saying the son of the mask that's that's
their that's their one right there man
that's the one
Oh genuinely geeky guys oh I got a
couple here from genuinely geeky guys I
thought you owned experiencing it nah
you are not the only one who experienced
in nipple chills all right look you're
but I'm sure if I just talk to my
nipples long enough it'll eventually
just get hard if I talked if I
encouraged them all you know we should
do is eventually when we up our
production value again we all have a
separate nipple cam in the corner
that'll just monitor when they get hard
or not yes and then you know what's mean
one good thing about that but yes Jane
you a geeky guys always proclaim the
nipple chip
no matter we go out if you feel it let
it you know what it always makes for an
easy laugh to in public I could always
tell which guest has never watched the
channel when I say hey nipples feels
little anything to play on like I've
said it a billion times
you said you watch this chant you don't
watch the catchphrase why [ __ ] you're
lying it's not a tight food no they're
all great everyone who comes on the
channel genuinely is a great human being
but thank you genuinely geek yeah is
really kind of you yeah
what's game grumps ever heard of that
and grumps is a YouTube channel
Philly death to smoochy and according to
Roca the movie clue
I love Glee people loves clues great
whoa is Roca thinking that's a guilty
pleasure clue is so much fun
guys go to outlaw nation channel
subscribe so you can tell them how wrong
and tell Roca his subjective opinions
are wrong tell him he's wrong death to
smoochy it's a pretty dark she's really
a guilty pleasure that's 100% sure guys
I'm just gonna I'm gonna like Neil
because this chairs getting
uncomfortable here so I'm doing this to
pray to you guys and to show you guys my
worship everyone who's here in this chat
right now then I'm gonna squat us to
make you know myself work harder are you
guys in quarantine seems super close to
each other this is not social distancing
guys well yeah I'll be back here John
get back there alright now we did this
should be the next thumbnail but we
succeed are we six feet apart yeah the
next livestream thumbnail should be this
I'm gonna get into the window can you
still have our alright can you guys
still here John alright so where were we
at here with the okay clueless clueless
is another that's another good know love
I grew up on them that's another good
movie except for the creepy thing with
the whole brother stepbrother thing who
those fans defend that I know social
justice warriors who will defend the
[ __ ] out of that choice step-sibling
should be fine that's the kind of point
I get to actually I once won
to make a romantic comedy that was in
that vein we're like one guy's dad and
one girl's mom meet but then like they
meet and yeah
that's that sounds like a great one
Indiana Jones for swingin definitely
don't I do not like that movie yeah I am
so bored whenever I watch it they're my
favorite Universal Studios ride they
used to be at the park was Back to the
Future the right at Terminator 3d we
need
Universal Studios Universal Studios for
everyone everyone gets to go and dress
everyone should be able to go to
Universal Studios right everyone going
every major country in the world
Alvarado and yes you know I I gotta say
this is not a nostalgia speaking III
think Ruth like just if you review what
they replaced them with terminate at
Universal Studios I already still at
Orlando I think some of them are are at
either Orlando or some of the parks
overseas guys I better see more guilty
pleasures going in this in this in this
live stream right a guilty pleasure
films nipple chills and guilty pleasure
TV shows and how about this let's our
fourth one out there songs do that most
people don't really like but you
honestly pretty much enjoy for me as a
guy it's pretty much all Britney Spears
and some Ashlee Simpson all right uh but
yeah they were placed back to the future
the ride with The Simpsons ride which i
think is a total blah I think the
Simpsons Ride is a lot of fun it's about
I think back to the future ride is
exceptionally more exciting
it's a classic too and that's scary when
I was a kid I feel my brother and my dad
always that we were in the front of the
car and back to the future and I got so
scared that I like went to the back in
the middle of the road it felt real
Terminator 3d I just got I'm gonna say
this right now [ __ ] that Despicable Me
right
that is a terrible ride and that should
never been replaced its relation and not
have they replaced oh my people still
love terminator I know that was terrible
terrible decision made yeah they should
bring back teach you 3d I gotta imagine
that that Despicable Me will eventually
fall off with those like if they stop
making those movies I don't think that
property was survive long in a park Mimi
I meet someone send me tow thank you
someone said that I sound like Eminem
and then the reaction that I did to the
Joyner Lucas video I flash an old video
where I was doing a rap song for Ryan
Gosling called dear Ryan you guys should
watch it
and I said sound like Eminem which is
the highest compliments highest
compliments now if only I could look
like Eminem and freestyle like Eminem
with the body of Chad Michael Murray
everyone always has an MCU actor with
that guy One Tree Hill Michael B thank
you so much dude Omni media go check out
his YouTube channel guy is an incredible
commentator Romney with a one in the
middle
saw the following three times in theater
go three times and this is these are all
movies before there was ever like a
Regal Cinemas pastor and AMC a-list
hateful fur that's a lot of money foot
towards these and a condom miss Spider
Man 3 and High School Musical 3 one of
these things is not like the others no
Mike I don't mean to judge you but uh
you know what I was good for you I'm
just like those are you a hot just just
like expound on your High School Musical
3 choice because that's the least
expected one for me and a condo was kind
of scary actually when it came out
Wilson in the body and I was scared
every time I lay low bathroom I was oh I
thought there was a snake in the toilet
I thought it was in the bathtub and it
kind of scared the crap out of me so
High School Musical through everywhere I
go I just see Vanessa Bolton in
spider-man 3 I did watch a couple times
the theater is the second time I watch
it I enjoyed it more as a sonic
IMAX so I got that cool spectacle of
things though I mean yeah I would much
rather watch spider-man 3
three times in the theatres as opposed
to three times at home oh there John
wick three is not a guilty pleasure come
on movies are beloved dodgeball is a
great comedy not a joke as well can I
meet you there Howard the Duck
definitely a guilty pleasure good call
right here
let's see Family Guy Family Guy's is
great fam for stick we genuinely like
the first half first fantastic
hey you virus leave us alone okay when I
was a kid I was the Red Power Ranger for
Halloween just want to point that out
for someone asking which power injury
would be I always got stuck is the blue
one but I always wanted Green House of
Wax that's another great Hellboy 20:19
that could definitely be a guilty
pleasure a good call right there I was
about to say which House of Wax Jared
Padalecki House of Wax or like Vincent
Price House of Wax
ooh Oh oh my god yes they will death
thank you geared towards sink Paul
Greengrass is about to do what you
you're your profile pic is representing
so many people in the world is this like
come on or Johnny Depp going through
divorce safety pins into your earlobes
and there you go but you're a
good-looking guy and it got the looks at
Johnny Depp when he was you know not
with amber hurt do you think they'll
make movies about Cove in 19 they're
already working on it you know the way
we work now that's a hot topic damn it
Megan
the only start writing a god damn
screenplay I can't wait for the news
headline Cove in nineteen film delayed
four oh okay what we got to make sure
we're keeping up here John dude awesome
guilty pleasures here I'm gonna look
over here not show Libre I I will join
you because I also love that movie yes
let's see what else more combat
annihilation well thank you Carter
Lovejoy for the contribution here he
says my guilty pleasure video Gant guys
guilty pleasure video games open it up
keep recommending to kill T question yes
too long somebody acknowledged not a
guilty pleasure that's yes
Carter Lovejoy says my guilty pleasure
video game are the ps2 Harry Potter game
yes those are fun yes if stealth
missions were my worst nightmare
Quidditch game was lit yes I had the
computer version of at least one of
those they were super fun in fact we
just did a Q&A asking about like video
game worlds we would go into and if it
wasn't such a cheat I would have said
Harry Potter game you know my alter-ego
my guilty pleasure video game I played
it forever and I only got to like level
two it was the hardest game in the world
it was Super Nintendo maybe some of you
guys are a little too young to know what
it is but Super Nintendo Super NES and
it was the Terminator 2 video
haha so the beginning you're at the bar
just massacring the [ __ ] out of people
with like bullets that look like little
white pellets and then you get on a
motorcycle once you've beat that
hard-ass level it's impossible to beat
then then you get on the motorcycle and
then and then you just like one crash
and you just explode and the level just
restarts all over again
that was a hard ass game and I just kept
playing it just get wouldn't stop
playing and I never got past level like
like years of trying to get past level 2
my my guilty pleasure game was farmville
yeah I spent some money back in the day
on my farmville and I yeah land around
Terminator dark fate you know some
people genuinely think that's actually
not a bad movie the faculty Faculty's
cool I think it's like relatively
accepted we're just deciding what is a
good or real guilt Roger
buying your guilt yeah we're gonna
redefine it right one week by barenaked
ladies I think that qualifies blood in
blood out
hey blood of blood outs a good movie
otherwise known as bound by honor fun
fact
Mickey was also Ken and Street Fighter
Ken was played by Damian Chapa I in
elementary school was best friend
with Rico Chapa Rico is a good guy okay
so I want to make sure we're not missing
anyone here spider-man three not even if
you don't need to be ashamed of it it's
better than amazing spider-man see I
think amazing spider-man 2 did like did
what's the word I'm looking for did
wonders for spider-man 3 yes it did it
did actually yeah because spider-man 3
you can take and break down and call
okay there are at least hole fragments
of this movie that are good and we're
gonna get at the point and this didn't
seem like it was ill conceived from the
very spider-man 3 may like that that
spanner I threw something got a lot more
brownie parts because it wasn't amazing
spider-man 2 then incredible how that
works out I love our culture I love the
way we offer right here ok 10 minute
thank you so much tomato songs new Raj
Krishna thank you again to ice the ice
pirate I feel like I've seemed like the
cover of this but I I don't care oh my
goodness let me Google let me giggle
this why are Google and I'm I keep
looking to this chat here to see what
else we got it is here keep these keep
these guilty pleasure coming Ozma I
wanted to see us Moses Jones in the
theaters so bad as a kid and I to this
day of not seeing it that was not an Al
Pacino impression it was a Bernie
Sanders impression like a very limited
range guys you have to understand this
one week by barenaked ladies oh hell
yeah I think I think anything by who's
the guy that people always make fun of
Bieber I know
exactly I know exactly who my uh who my
guilty pleasure band is this is a band I
listen to them and I genuinely think
it's like badass and no one likes them
Nickelback okay Nick I [ __ ] love
Nickelback I really do and everyone's
there like the go-to clown on band and
Dave Matthews oh I don't know I don't
listen to Dave Matthews but I know he's
like another clown all guy but
Nickelback just seems to be the popular
choice to clown on yeah but I I
genuinely like Nickelback they've got a
little too much these kind of it gets
the primer on the littles I'm
uncomfortable with how much I like
Nickelback yeah I'll catch myself
enjoying myself whoa
attack of the killer tomatoes George
Clooney Glee as a guilty pleasure show
for the most part uh you know what I've
heard a lot of Glee fans who watched a
lot of the show say is the first season
is legitimately good and then people
kept watching for like the schlock like
there were things like they genuinely
appreciate it but they I've often heard
it said that the quality was season one
Wow some of you guys are doing like
movies I've never heard of here rat one
night in Bangkok by Murray had it was
that one rat a towing rat Jason X I
think most of the Friday the 13th
franchise qualifies
Oh Britney Lynch tell us what her job is
thank you so much Britney oh I love
watching classic movies my go-to movie
is Seven Brides for Seven Brothers or
Calamity Jane and Gone with the Wind and
Breakfast it's no joke Britney you you
just named totally get along with my
girlfriend named the two Olivia's
favorite movies of all time woman Gone
with the Wind and Breakfast at Tiffany's
are her two absolute favorite films of
all time
mhm for the entire time of day but when
we gonna watch gone with the wind and
I'm I can't find myself willing to sit
down for almost four hours do split it
into episodes like Tarantino this is the
true it conflict at the heart of your
relations sum 41
All American Rejects move along hey I
like I like that
and I don't think I like All American
Rejects of a womanizer
ngo one - yeah good call and I like the
741 else I like that whole album
actually that's my favorite of their
albums before I kind of fell off the
train with them someone's asking what
what are we talking about our guilty
pleasures primarily utterly oh really
what'swhat's up would you get I have
from geared toward zinc geared toward
zinc
I actually just borrowed a copy of the
pick up C tapes from a friend of mine so
I've heard very divisive things and at
some point I'm gonna check that out well
thank you thank you so much geared
towards didn't keep up that Johnny Depp
look it looks great on you because he
cannot pull that off anymore no no not
not entirely he's having to come back
man and having to come back he's
potentially having to come back and he's
also like playing music now like the
Hollywood vampires have dropped two
albums all we had to do was leak some
real personal [ __ ] and yeah just area of
laundry out of the world and the thing
is like I make fun of that but I eat it
up I'll be I'll be up a laying in bed my
woman just on the phone watching like
the deposition for Amber thank you dear
towards ink okay what time is it ghost
writer spirit of vengeance is another
one that's another great one have a
fever pitch
I want to make su Lander is a family
favorite so I have no guilt personally
but yeah I think that's a good guilty
pleasure movie I want to make sure I'm
not missing anyone here grandpa's
birthday message Sandra's chasing you I
thought it was the own experience nipple
just bear with me for one second guys
while I'm just really quickly going
through this ice pirates do you think
they may okay yeah Robbie Williams in
Popeye I think that's where we are what
are you talking about go back try and
make sure I don't miss any the second we
don't interact properly we lose everyone
on this live station Newton is Robin
Williams as Popeye you know what I don't
know how well the Popeye motion pictures
aged but I will say that his Popeye
performance I was like wow he's really
doing pop I know you killed I thought he
killed it yeah yeah absolutely kill it
good call on that Jason you know mmm
good one
what's your favorite Robin Williams
movie mine is what's a bad Robin
Williams movie to fit this joke in want
to go back to death just what's that toy
is that the Todd Salons movie Oh
genuine guys hey he said thank you so
much you said you'd say it's a yeah say
his comment in the John Travolta
impression please never do John Travolta
again I feel like that voice yeah it's
really bad in fact I want to see the
fanatic because I have a feeling that
will become a guilty pleasure right
quick Jason Nunez is saying the TV show
oh belongs to lungs the oblongs yeah no
there's no there there can not read
these glasses uh can you talk to my
optometrist your glasses are just fine
but he's a Virgo just like me that is
like you and I we should say hey my
doctor say guys know the TV show blogs a
weird show and Deanne wood song I fink
you freaky I think you freaky and I love
you a lot I mean the Deanne wood is is
great weren't they the ones in chappy
yeah yeah oh god so good dee Antwoord
music I'd like there one where I can see
why they would be a normal pleasure and
a guilty pleasure at the same time oh
yeah absolutely yeah uh I got a copy all
right what else do we got here No thank
you so much Jay sterling dude thank you
thank you everyone so far by the way
really do you appreciate it
Oh buckaroo banzai I love them oh great
call I love it Mortal Kombat
annihilation yeah Mortal Kombat Mortal
Kombat annihilation such a terrible film
but such a blast
such a blast yeah I you know I like it
really I don't know what was gonna
happen there with the
words go watch the short Mortal Kombat
film from a few years back that was like
a super cool surprise at the time Space
Jam you know we said that thing about
Space Jam not being a good movie but
like it's a childhood favorite and there
were the comments in a video it always
said that and they were like like what
do you mean Space Jam I couldn't move
wait what what are you talking about
what did you say where's that unsub
budding fun fact go to Space Jam calm in
the site from 96 is still the same as
it's ever been
oh I've seen a lot of people naming off
these Friedberg Seltzer movies and those
are true guilty yeah I mean comedy is
probably the most subjective of them all
Archer go poop right now it's good for
you you'll feel better a lot of times we
relate to getting videos up because
that's what I'm doing so I understand
the stress buddy had a horrible
nightmare situation when I went on a run
not long ago that was scary almost had a
very terrifying embarrasses situation
sometimes you have too much fiber the
day before true story
that's what I'm here for hey man at
least you're keeping regular people
worse than is better than being
concentrated on a run we got a few here
all right okay first off that 70 shows a
genuinely good show the last couple
seasons do fault Little Shop of Horrors
babe there's something about mary
chitty-chitty-bang-bang grease and brat
you name primarily of these films are
these relatively well regarded these are
not guilty pleasures all right like fun
fact about babe those same directors Mad
Max all right guys we gotta get off of
here in just a couple minutes but we
want to make sure we're doing or we're
up to date with everything right now
I've been promising mikemaya I am a
recent pescetarian and I've been telling
my girlfriend all day today we are going
to be going to Del Taco to get some
beyond tacos and if you guys are vegan
or vegetarian those beyond tacos [ __ ]
incredible and impossible whoppers to
yes just letting you know agreed just
letting you know but you want to make
sure I'm not missing anyone here Oh
Dodger Ryan guilty pleasure movie
stealing Harvard I remember when we came
out Thank You jaja Ryan buddy who are
those people in the thumbnail with you
Oh
- woman what a sailor huh - what next
are you but you know you're you do what
you talk - girl touch her can you
introduce me to one or both it doesn't
look like anyone's Taj and Ryan you know
what I mean see you saw girls and I saw
like mobsters Irishmen posters Billy the
Kid Lawrence how's it going buddy we
sometimes talk on Twitter I just pointed
out as I was reading this is a GP
hearing back from Greg months between
messes dad is a guild slash that is a
guilty pleasure if you ever hit me up on
social media I am the worst at
responding to messages on social media
every once in a while I'll get back and
it's usually started with sorry man
finally getting back to you this is with
everyone like it's been like a year but
I'm getting around I read your text and
I'm continuing this conversation that's
how most of my conversation even though
I say that I still respond as if I I
just got this message yeah well that's
the problem with Texas because like the
last message just is the last message to
me really
well thanks Billy the Kid Lawrence means
a hell of a lot Michael B's back high
school thank you Mike Reedy thanks so
much man doesn't have a regal pass to
use it's put it all towards super chat
here good man this is the way we arere a
subscription service of our very Ahonen
High School Musical 3 because I was a
show choir kid in high school it
paralleled my senior year a lot and
triggers a lot of fond memories I feel
like this why you and your girlfriend
are having problems you're just singing
it stop singing look I don't want to
bring your personal life into this
Michael but is this why you and your
girlfriend has have not been you know
I'm just messing with you Michael his
girlfriend and him are doing great
orgies all the time that's the sign of
any healthy relationship well I can
respect that dude I can respect that I
feel like I've learned that you sang
before and was very surprised to answer
but yeah
dancer dude Michael beejac of so many
trades Alexa bliss is your guilty
pleasure oh those are the two people
they're with you listen Nikki cross
they're cool cool
those are wrestlers John yes as a
wrestlers in case you don't know when I
heard Nikki cross I I went okay Oh as
Alexa bliss that did it for me oh and we
got the two halves guys but I wanted to
tell everyone here just throwing it out
there is geared towards sync on his
Instagram page he draws portraits on
wait a minute did I meet you at a party
do you know Aaron Alexander because
there was someone who did that kind of
work and he drew portraits on his shoes
and it was like it was awesome art on
shoes it was great stuff it looks like
he was ripping Johnny Depp off no wait
that guy was totally Asian definitely
Asian but guys we got a fun send me a
message I'll follow you and reply to
that message in a year from now mhm
thank you geared toward sync and we'll
order some shoes in two years I used to
watch Jason Nunez good call I used to
watch this show we went to school of st.
Charles and elementary and junior high
and in the morning on a channel which I
don't know if it's still around
weirdly this aired on the channel UPN
and I would watch it every single
morning that was a cool show yeah it
really was an inventive show god I
remember you good call
channel 13 and then it fused with WB to
become the CW I'm not sure I'll ever
shave my beard as long as as long as my
girlfriend Erik going strong now might
be I have seen i Frankenstein pop up so
many times in this talk everyone moving
sure it's fun
good call on a three ninja like a
billion at those fun fact for you Lana
woof was it what let this purchase
brought it up in elementary school my
brother went was in the same grade as
the actor who is one of the green ninja
in the fourth green green inches movie
it was Matthew and he like he was in
eighth grade and then they had something
where kids for the elementary class got
like older Big Brother sort of thing and
I didn't choose my actual brother I
chose the guy who started that's great
damn they let you not be with your own
sibling that's that's yeah I said no I
live with him punches me I want to
experience a different sibling to be
right back that Johnny Depp look all
right guys you don't view more here then
we're gonna happen call it Nickelback
okay oh oh we got a couple here from
Nickelback
oh we know we got a few a we got an
order or Tonya Janata Tonya Janata - no
I'm from England
iced Ventura oh she's doing emojis
that's what we're trying to honor right
yeah hi Tonya from England how's it
going out there talking with some people
in England yeah I was Boris Johnson
doing I'm not doing well not doing well
symptoms now didn't Prince Charles get
it Williams which one was it
if they ain't American I don't follow
properly and I hope things are sane ish
where you are make sure when we got
along didn't you go to swat a and some
crumpets move go down low six when your
chimney oh we're all will Chitty Chitty
Bang Bang genuinely geeky thank you so
much to my friends said Batman and Robin
and I don't get it oh that's a yeah
Batman and Robin I kind of get it
genuine you guys because ever been
around was the kind of film were I
started and I'm having a blast then
about 25 minutes in I suddenly have this
like
tumor grows it literally goes from like
this is so fun too
why is my head pounding right now how
did this happen so I guess I don't get
it either yeah but thank you pizza slice
Nickelback haters meme we're there in
itself lol they've got good sauce god
bless this didn't run for real oh so god
bless the Simpsons hit and run
never made it as a wise man
Nickelback hey yeah I know yeah you know
what
Nickelback I will defend to the end and
they're pretty cool about it these days
so props to them they've managed to have
fun with it
Billy the Kid you want to do it again or
do I get to do your cool oh you do it
knew it Nickelback Billy the Kid thank
you so much for the super chat there
buds
what is it let's do okay Nickelback up
to 2010 is great haters hate got a
defender here thank you thank you very
much about time it's about time
especially now that may imagine dragons
is becoming the go to scapegoat band
yeah people like show up to Nickelback
shows [ __ ] trailer oh great call TMNT
out of the shadows an amazing guilty
pleasure hmm I really had a great time
watching that mice on theaters love
didn't and was fully aware it was not a
good movie easily Stephen Amell zwarst
work alright what else we got here Ian
so tell Oh from patreon oh you guys
should do a music review for Louis
Capaldi he's a pretty cool guy like you
guys cuz I imagine you say yes thank you
by the way he insula Sotelo
here's I imagine him saying this you
guys should do a music room for Louis
Kapali beat cop a cop a lady whatever
yeah he's a pretty cool guy thank you
guys oh now I'm imagining me going yeah
alright this very cool I check out some
stuff music thank you thank you
so good recommendation preciate that all
right guys got a lot about further bit
so we're gonna speed around some of
these good quality okay
Andrew ah drew is it worth renting birds
of prey for twenty dollars I say yes yes
I say yes really liked I say hold on to
the rest of super chats and you just
used the rest of that money to go to
renting birds of prey show them some
support go improve their Bob that like
please go do it yeah of all the movies
to get a weird reception like that I was
like this 100 and Britney laying oh we
finally got it Thank You Britney I work
in retail the company I work for his
painting approach at the time we were
off work well go on a spending spree
it's gonna turn around by April people
take care of everything go on a spending
spree eventually if they pause your rent
because you'll definitely not have to
pay back later yes they're not gonna
come and shaft you for six months after
this is all done well I'm glad you're
being able to get paid for right now you
know because there's some people I know
who aren't so I'm glad you're able to
right now and for those who are still
working do show your appreciation if you
happen to like go to a Starbucks or
something do give a tip yeah cuz they're
they're putting their lives
I mean yeah their health their health at
risk yeah tip tip like much better than
you ever would say if you can five
dollars for a cup of coffee tip twenty
dollars mm-hm and then ask for some
change but like only a small specific
amount alright we're almost to the end
your charger Ryan 1:24 thank you so much
my diamond dude another one one WM AC
master what is will Mac John look it up
wonder man against crime masters 1wm AC
masters who's gonna assume who's gonna
explain in the chat before we finally
figured out what an American live-action
television show featuring choreographed
martial arts fights it was produced by
4kids productions in conjunction with
blah blah blah and WMA C stands for the
fictional World Martial Arts Council
where they compete for the ultimate
prize the Dragons star okay that guilty
pleasure because that sounds pretty
awesome yeah go check that out go down
and installed your whole Godzilla 98
yeah I could get on board with that I
enjoy that for that it is obviously
terrible but I enjoy it oh good night
Hey Oh Quentin Tarantino's because it'd
be called Quinton quarantine Oh
apparently Annie Olsen thank you so much
my dear think again
let's go with the bang ever glow don't
dawn John makes sense of that before we
have to end this please hello I've
waited here for you pour myself into
that's ever long Adam ahead ever glow
ever glow whoops I definitely you just
[ __ ] up I am so sorry you know what
let's never glow then I'll start singing
ever glory Annie I'm not the brains
you're sorry effort Oh Bernie Alvarado
in my MI out Pacino impression my
favorite my favorite soundtrack
gladiator what source talk about like
the movie soundtrack I guess so oh
that's oh okay alright well Bernie
Alvarado you know my favorite one is uh
uh out of the movies I'll share with you
guys my favorite one it would be the
Dark Knight Hans Zimmer all over that
[ __ ] just [ __ ] with [ __ ] beautiful
music that's high interpreted also I
figured it out and ever glow is a girl a
group in the Cayard a pop world so I
think that's a song request ever glow
they'll be Olson for the recommendation
here where are you from
Dodger Ryan Moore will come combat
conquest 98 I had that how was it it was
amazing good call there Dodger Ryan yeah
say hi to Alexis bliss for me and and
Nikki Kovac in and Riley read and and
and Shania Twain all the names I learned
at that last wrestling event we were at
and then didn't retain good night to the
few people who have left at all you
beautiful loves ok oh ok and Niraj er oh
we got here no Raj Krishnan to close
this out got an ID oh we did do it on we
did you go where did you go from
cotton-eye Joe that's a great call
Karan I J I I think there's continent
was Conan I joke like a lot it's six
flags total yes a day
they love that song those employees were
like this is what everyone wants to
listen to you
why rating line to go on the riddler
right cotton-eye Joe and those couple of
vanga boys songs were like the Six Flags
three key song playlist
yes absolutely like oh and then you just
have visions of that freaky not old man
old man all right guys well this hey
thank you so much thanks for watching
the cosmic wonder video everybody check
it out guys there's so many of you guys
hanging out with us here on the Saturday
night this was a total blast had a lot
of fun probably the longest livestream
we've ever done and the most engaged
I kneel for you guys thank you guys so
much for being you and be safe keep
practicing social distancing yes you
guys have some last dragon great call oh
um dragging the Bruce Lee story that's
another guilty pleasure of mine I would
definitely say the white guy Bruce Lee
movie from last year is my guilty
pleasure but guys I just wanted to say
be safe be saying wise be kind and do
what you can to help clear your mind
whenever it feels like you're getting
cabin fever okay thank you guys so much
there's this way to people who list off
right now thank you guys for showing
your support here in the super
generously much love to all you I'm
gonna go get del Taco I'll let you know
how it is
tune in next week
due to dudududududududududududu I wanted
to do the bit where we pretend to log
off and then we just send really racist
stuff but then I was like nah bit cancel
have more videos going up on on Monday
but thank you guys so much for being
here
you're welcome been amazing thank you
thank you everyone who tuned in these
are really fun and like to have you guys
here it really means a lot especially
during this time love you all 3,000 mr.
3000 Thorburn a mac movie great guilty
Doris world quote we need to know how to
log off whatever it takes a log off its
this button right here good night and
good luck
see you guys
you